this is a production of Cornell
University okay well MA Bryant
Schlesinger and my friends at Bryant
Park now that the ice rink is often
there in Manhattan
the site is regraded and the staff
decided to go out and mow big heart so
we're we're really rooting for all our
friends and loved ones in the
metropolitan New York area and Carl I
know a very own alumni of yours UConn
Stephanie runs the Madison Square Park
down there as well and we're all of
those people are on our minds these days
at the epicenter so we're happy to be
able to lay this down on videotape and
as well for those of you that can join
us live and hopefully you've got some
questions you know it's hard to you know
reconcile many things as they pass
through our minds these days media and
other things that are there we've been
through as a species some crisis in the
past that we have some recent memory of
and when we have leaders who call upon
us to do certain things which maybe
doesn't include injecting Lysol into our
I couldn't help myself Carl I had to I
had to do it this morning so good to see
you all anyway there are still resources
that are out there available to you that
our Cooperative Extension people do not
to dwell on this too much but it
continues to be updated the government
is you know now in a phase where the
numbers are doing certain things that
they are not we're not getting these
sort of big shifts in the things we're
doing there's still quite a bit of
confusion about the things way things
are going on but in general I would say
landscape and lawn care and grounds are
working maybe not to the degree that
they'd like to be all the time one of
the things that's important in our
industry is that we do work with we
interact with the public
I mean golf courses can stay away from
people to a certain extent because
organized sports aren't going on sports
can stay away from people if you're in
the grounds area and your university or
facility is is currently not open
obviously that social distancing becomes
a little bit easier but but I can tell
you from recent trips to the grocery
store not everybody's getting this
social distancing thing and especially
that we're in employment and working and
out in the public
we've got specific guidance in New York
State for the way we want to handle that
all right let's look at the weather
we've been going through for the last
several weeks rather than just go
through all the slides of temperature I
can tell you that we were warming up for
a period of time during the season and
now have hit a stall I think one of the
things I realized from chatting with
people in all aspects of turf is you
know I've got to stop myself from doing
the things I normally do at this time
especially if you if your system is
normally getting traffic like it doesn't
golfing sports where you're using
nutrients to sort of keep up with the
wear and tear but in the lawn and
grounds area where traffic either may or
may not be greater or lesser you should
be able to moderate some of your
nutrient management some of your weed
control some of your other practices to
address the fact that the growing season
is is not really progressing it did and
then for the last several weeks it
stopped and we were joking yesterday
with our weather person Artie Caetano I
think it snowed more in April up here in
upstate New York than it snowed all of
the winter next slide and here is the
growing degree day forecast for the
coming week now over the last three week
two weeks we've had basically
single-digit accumulations and we don't
expect much more than 15 degrees to
accumulate we've had very few days in
much of the Northeast where average
temperature has been above 50 degrees
and so when that happens you're not
accumulating now how does that how does
that translate well in one way it
translates specially in the lawn and
grounds area where weeds are going to be
a big component of your services we have
models that we've adapted that were used
in and developed in the Midwest and and
validated across much of the northern
United States to indicate that when you
get about a hundred and fifty base 50
growing degree days
accumulated by from March first you had
about 150 to 200 you start to see become
a favorable time to apply post-emergent
broadleaf we control with 240 and that
was a model designed for dandelions and
240 use for control and so if you just
use that as a barometer for when many of
your perennials might be susceptible in
the spring to an herbicide application
and you've got reduced staff and you
just can't you know do your normal apps
the way you did timing those
applications is going to be even more
critical now the Esther formulation of
240 which we recommend for dandelion
control early right we don't recommend
it when it gets warmer because Esther
formulations have a bad habit of
volatilizing these formulations are one
of the primary causes of landscape plant
vegetable plant damage early in the
spring is the application of these
products when young plants or emerging
spring growth is happening in the
landscape you apply this it gets really
warm like 80 degrees and all of a sudden
the chemicals will volatilize move with
the Veit width and drift as a vapor and
injure nearby plants this is one of the
most common injuries that we see in the
landscape that we'll probably talk about
next week as we bring a weed scientist
back in but just a note that that right
now it's way too early even in a
metropolitan New York area it's way too
early to be applying many of these
broadly three controls post emergence
all right now from a growth and
fertilizer perspective we've really
grown accustomed to using this growth
potential you know how much can the
grass possibly grow and I know Carl's
done a lot of in-depth research in you
know the pool of nitrogen in the soil
and the quality of the turf and is there
a way we can calibrate these things and
where we know that the soil is that part
of the puzzle we don't understand
completely yet whether it's microbial
activity and mineralization of nitrogen
soil nitrate pool
those sorts of things are still under
research but we have some guides that in
general if photosynthetic activity maxes
out in the mid-60s as you can see again
on this chart if it maxes out here in
the mid to late mid to late mid to upper
60s right and you're only averaging 50
degrees temperature you only got about
25% chance to grow you're not gonna be
able to grow very much which
theoretically which means they you know
you're not gonna respond to fertilize
very much which brings us to the
conversation for today with my longtime
colleague and pal carp yard Karl when
you did this I'm going to go through a
couple of slides and then I'll get to
some questions along the way but I want
to make sure everybody understands this
is online and available the New England
interstate Water Pollution Control
Commission and what I've liked about
this and I think Marty participated in
it as well Marty Petrovic emeritus
professor here at Cornell University
participated in this and was able to you
know get recommendations out there that
were based around one of the ecosystem
services of turf that it's really going
to be useful especially in urban
environments for keeping the water clean
and so there's the way they approach it
is pretty classic it was done with focus
groups and industry participation so
what I like about it is it's seems
cooperative it's the kind of thing that
if it moves to regulation is it looks
like it's going to be well informed so
how are they approaching it well it's
the five RS right everybody knows these
top four but as they write in the
narrative of this if you take a minute
to look at it that last one that's you
know what are the right things that
support these actions and support the
turfs ecosystem services the supporting
services that urban grasslands provide
by retaining stormwater and nutrients
now let's start with a few --'tis that
are pretty obvious and worth talking
about with our current weather
conditions and then we'll get to the
questions in a minute but right now one
of the guidelines is around right time
there's right product is Right rate
right formulation there's right rate
there's a number of things in here I'm
gonna highlight a few one
we're expecting a pretty good wet
washout over the next several days our
weather forecast is indicating as much
as two to three inches in some locations
and the least amount of rain anyone's
going to get in the Northeast is about
an inch over the next five to seven days
so if you look at guideline 18 and 19
now ain't the right time folks and so to
speak in in New York language if you
will it's not the right time to be
putting down fertilizer because we're
sort of we're likely to get a fair
amount of water and we could get some
help with this if we could continue to
get manufacturers to put these kinds of
notes the regional guideline number 20
highlights do not apply a near water
storm drain such-and-such okay what
about the right place now this is what's
very interesting because we're going to
be really wet the soils are gonna be
already saturated I almost feel like the
entire urban environment to some extent
is a--
is a UH an urban turf my sucked to some
extent is a sensitive area because
because it's so much associated with the
pavement now if you look at the right
place I'm sorry the environmentally
sensitive areas but and it's the amount
of nitrogen that you put down so if you
have a sensitive area the guidelines say
no more than a half a pound of n per
thousand per application and
three-quarters of a pound in a single
application which means the other point
too has to be slow release nitrogen and
they're also saying that in these
sensitive areas you shouldn't put on
more than two pounds total
now that's very much in line what we've
said last year when the nitrogen
regulations came up and we were saying
well what's a justifiable rate of
nitrogen and you're thinking about Long
Island being a sensitive location
especially for nitrogen this is very
much these are very much in line with
what we've been promoting to the
legislature should they be considering
some form of regulation now what about
right supporting actions in here roughly
it's saying mow high leave the clippings
if you can't leave the clippings don't
let them be on paved surfaces how many
times have you heard us say this and
rightness and this is one of the
characteristic problems we have
of urban grasslands by definition their
blooded up against some sort of pavement
so mow high leave the clippings if you
can't make sure they're not going into
the into the stormwater and then finally
some of the right supporting actions
that address the compost discussion we
had last week number one organic
materials should be tested if you're
gonna try to fix your soil you should
know what you're doing and be very
careful because phosphorus is a big
issue if you're using bio solids we
certainly want you to know what you're
doing and it looks like it should be
trace amounts I think was the term we we
mentioned last time if it has phosphate
above trace amounts because if you start
putting a quarter and a half an inch of
it on even with trace amounts it winds
up being a lot of phosphorus so Carl
this is where I'll bring you back in
here pal for our conversation today
thanks for taking the time I want to
start maybe they're really the place to
go at is do you agree a little bit with
my assessment of these areas being in
urban areas when the soils are saturated
being sensitive sites that we should
maybe but be observed the sensitive site
part of this guideline oh yeah I think
you're you're absolutely right with that
area I mean when we look at these our
urban areas and one of my former
colleagues at UConn Jack Clausen he
always told me when you're looking at
water quality you know follow the water
so in any urban areas you know we're
gonna have a lot of impervious services
and areas where water is just going to
particularly the runoff water is gonna
be channeled directly into into
receiving waters so I think anything
that we can do to prevent any potential
contamination coming from as you
mentioned either clippings or and
certainly if fertilizers and that
includes both the synthetic and the
organics is that all that can move so if
if we can direct those and and as the
whole I agree with the whole concept of
visit
in terms of the four of the fogger the
five ours on doing that I guess the
challenge of doing that we can say all
this all that we want but actually
putting it into practice and I think
that's where the challenge is
particularly for a lot of the the
professional folks that are doing this
and often times it may have to be that
each property may be slightly adjusted
in terms of almost a well would be
ideally it should be site-specific right
and how to dial in you know in changing
from property to property to price so
let's start with some easy stuff let me
start with some easy questions first off
what I don't see I mean I think it's
mentioned in there a couple of times but
one of the things that we start out with
it makes it really easy for people to
understand is if you have an older lon
that's had grass on it for a while
inherently it should need less nutrients
across the board so if you're trying to
be site-specific and you think well how
the heck do I do that I like to tell
people just start with how old the lawn
is if it's young it might need some more
help but if it's older it's gonna have
that reservoir in the organic matter
that it supplies that it's going to be
able to draw on can you talk about that
for a little bit Carl is that a good
first cut with how to determine how much
to fertilize just age of the lawn sure
no I think the work from your Institute
long and long ago long ago yeah I think
it was porter in the early 80s or late
seventies 72
yeah okay well indicated and I think
their data and their modeling show does
you get a lawn that's about 10 years old
then that that increase in the soil
organic matter and the nitrogen is gonna
be pretty much equal IR equilibrated at
that point so I some of the
recommendations that we've had as you
get into a mature lawn and let's say
let's let's pick a benchmark point you
know 10 years you're approaching 10
years and Beyond you should be able to
reduce the nitrogen
input into that because if he's done
start to exceed that it's not gonna have
the capacity to absorb we don't have
finite capacity of holding on in
retaining that nitrogen we're gonna get
to some equilibrium through that so I
think and also you'd mentioned about
returning clippings so this whole
concept of older lawns returning
clippings on there and I would I would
suggest or I would guess that many of
these areas that have been receiving say
historical rates of X number of pounds
of nitrogen per year I pay in those if
they were cut down by a third or a half
I doubt if they would be much difference
in terms of the visual quality or
performance on those okay so so so
that's perfect that's the exact answer I
and if you have an older lawn and you
start to reduce your fertilizer it's
unlikely you're gonna notice and we've
heard this when we started our potassium
research many years ago you know people
were throwing potassium like crazy we
were like what what what are you doing
and then people would stop applying
especially in the Gulf space they'd stop
applying it and then they wouldn't say
it publicly they come to me and aside is
he you know I haven't applied potassium
like five years and I barely noticed it
so that's so that's the first thing but
let's hone in on the spring here because
now you know at the jump
everybody wants we defeat especially in
the lawn and ground smart and large
landscapes of production oriented
operations much like lawn and grounds
are different than sports and golf
they're very production oriented they're
very you know here's what we do when we
cover our 3000 lawns or we take care of
our ten properties and here's the way we
do it we deploy them and it's a matter
of how fast the truck can get there
through their due diligence and get out
and I'm not suggesting there's anything
wrong with that
but I'm wondering now at this kovin
situation we do staff having to send out
all the trucks not want so much growth
how would you approach what you know
about nitrogen use in the spring under
these conditions yeah
one other aspect - about nitrogen uptake
in grass is oftentimes we tend to forget
is that it has to come through there has
to be water moving through the plant and
I know I've spent a lot of time and I
know we're in the spring here but I've
spent a lot of work kind of dialing in
with fall fertilization and the work
that you were involved with on the paper
that sold that Doug sold that put out he
was last year at the International yep
yeah just excellent papers looking at
nitrogen uptake in plants with
temperature and et and so it was those
papers in that research and I've got
data on that too from past research
basically shows it gets colder you're
gonna have less and less uptake of that
but we haven't necessarily taken that
information and moved it to the spring
as well there you know the physics don't
change okay okay okay
but how come a couple weeks ago we had
Doug sold out he actually may be on here
right now we had them on and and and
I've always sort of well why is the
grass starting to grow early where is it
getting the nitrogen it's been cold it's
been wet and it still greens up and
starts to grow in some places so it
can't just be water movement no well I
am absolutely convinced with that and I
think we've got some data that will be
coming out soon to show that plants and
the grasses and the green up of that is
is due largely to the stored nitrogen
from the previous fall so I think from
an agronomic standpoint where the fall
fertilization concept it does work
agronomically you know the plant there
needs to be a certain amount of mass of
nitrogen that the plant accumulates out
and then it's gonna utilize that and
especially for the spring green and I
know if anybody who's been involved in
in managing with grass it's almost like
somebody flips a switch sometime in the
spring then all of a sudden it just
greens up but from a water movement and
uptake it can't be coming primarily from
water uptake it had to come from I
believe that what
it's been stored within within the plant
and so we're using that that concept and
that hypothesis to look at that nitrogen
within the plant at that time and how
it's going to affect plant growth and
development and then how can we use that
information to help us guide our
nitrogen rates from that so that's some
work we've got on and that'll be coming
out coming out shortly but up until we
have some actual true objective
measurements on there let's face it
we're just guessing
sometimes we guess right I would suspect
a lot of times we guess wrong and if you
guess wrong in terms of putting more on
than you eat you're not gonna see
changes from the plant visually you know
from an agronomic standpoint that's fine
the plant it's not necessarily gonna
hurt the plant but from a water quality
standpoint yeah we're gonna have so
we're gonna have conflicting goals
relative to environmental goals and
agronomy codes now exactly right now I
know you spent a lot of time researching
this and one of the measures you uses
color everybody wants their grass to
green up and and if you looked at what
you know people complain about in the
spring it's weeds and why isn't my lawn
as green as the neighbors and and and
greening up and and so you is using
color a good way to determine when to
put on nitrogen no yes with a caveat in
that assuming all other factors that
affect color have been controlled for
yeah yeah sure well you have insects
temperatures water all can absolutely
affect assuming that those have either
been controlled for or our optimum roof
in the range of acceptable then
certainly color now let's face it we
have been using color in turf grass
managers and using color to guide their
management for ever ever you know you
asked many long-term managers and they
have a really good intuitive sense
they'll look at the grass say well I got
to put a little bit on I'm not gonna put
anything on and what are they basically
doing they're using their visual color
and experience to do that do you find
that when they do that do they often
times over fertilize well I think they
can I mean the human eye is good human
eye and I think the data that Richardson
and Karcher put out I think the human
eye is pretty good at detecting
differences that are pretty disparate
apart you get closer and closer and
closer human eye is not good for
detecting out very very slight
differences where in many times
interfaces can make a big difference
between optimum amounts and excess or
above optimum okay I want to shift gears
just for a second and talk a little bit
about compost because we've had this
recurring theme and we think especially
in the lawn and grounds market physical
properties of soils are big problems and
obviously one of the solutions to that
is the incorporation and regular use of
compost now one of the we hear that
mantra and you've heard it and you
addressed it in this publication and I
have to say in most cases you basically
were saying if you're gonna use this
thing this is a problem you better be
really careful about the way you use it
and how you use it and so we've seen
some work trying to use sources of
compost that are not so ladened with
phosphorus how do you talk to people
about trying to fix oil physical
properties Carl as and and you know sold
that says just build another soil on top
of it unless you're gonna fill the grass
you know the compost then it's gonna be
hard to fix and I think he's right about
that where are you on this use of
compost in the lawn and ground space
yeah well I'm not necessarily against it
and certainly you know compost is very
good for for remediating out certain
aspects but but it's not necessarily
benign to the environment you know just
because it's comes from organic sources
and such on that it doesn't mean that
you can continually load that on and
especially in in in established systems
stratification and layers upon layers
higher and higher and you think some of
the data especially with the phosphorus
even though it may be low phosphorus as
you had mentioned before some of the
compost rates that are putting on their
low concentration but at high rates
you know sometimes meat meets those
critical environmental levels and where
you have higher concentrations up near
the surface that's gonna be more
amenable to moving off with with surface
water especially this time of the year
on frozen soil right so with that so the
big challenge of course is how do we
guide this now recently my student David
Moore and and and I put out a and and my
colleague Tom Morris have put out a
series of papers recently where this is
what we're trying to look at can we
utilize some sort of these new
biological soil tests to look at the
carbon dioxide rates coming out of soils
or some certain fractions of nitrogen
coming out to help guide that and write
some of our data suggest that yeah we
could we could take and especially I
think for folks that are managing and
utilizing compost these tests may have
really good promise on helping helping
guide that so it definitely begins with
you if you're going to use compost it
definitely begins with you testing it
and and Carl as we wrap up I want to
just draw our attention to this again a
fertilization program in that
publication that that's basically saying
if you fertilize twice a year it's
saying late April to early May less than
a 7/10 of a pound
most of the nitrogen should be slow
release so you know three times still
keeps us under the two pounds but a lot
of people as you see here are basically
just saying what you're showing in the
New England climate in the Northeast
once a year in sensitive sites just to
maintain that turf density is going to
be is going to be really
so so you still like this chart right
Karl for for guiding the way the
landscape and grounds people should be
feeding
based on what we have to help us guide
especially for rates I think this is
this is reasonable I think it's
reasonable
of course I think the weakness with
everything we do is that we really don't
know what the correct rate is I know
we're making assumptions it's like Oh
point nine point five point seven to me
these are still all arbitrary you can
take that I'm following this guide I'm
doing it very well but if you have a
soil that has really high mineralization
capacity say years and years of compost
applications returning your clippings
and you start putting down these rates
on here let's not think that we're still
gonna protect water quality by doing
that yes I think this is we need these
sort of guidance to start out with but
okay so I think we need common sense to
help us guide that and not necessarily
blind well I followed this
recommendation that you said and you put
out there for I am doing everything
environmentally responsible you know
please let's let's take some
responsibility as well for for and I've
had people where I've given talks and
and some of the lawn care companies that
have hundreds if not thousands of
customers that's saying I hear what
you're saying and I agree with it but
how can we do this individually for each
age you know for them time is money and
it's most efficient to calibrate
everything to give a uniform rate just
let me go bettan go in and so you know
but but also we've got to use some
common sense I'm doing this to hopefully
coming up so with the technologies
that's being developed in and with big
data and the sensors and you know man
drugs and things like that I think we're
gonna be able to get a lot of data
coming in
then also the work that Doug sold at and
you folks did at Cornell with the
temperature and et I think yeah and
that's of course you know that that's of
course Marty's work that he was kind
enough to Marty and Doug's work that
they were kind enough to share with me I
was uh I was uh I was a ride-along on
that so let's ask if there's any
questions Carl there any questions there
see Carl yep so we got one from Kathy
good question we were talking earlier
about people putting down nitrogen
really to get the color and she's asking
if additional iron can improve the color
of the grass as a there's an alternative
to nitrogen how do you like iron Carl
for color rather than nitrogen well sure
it can work as a substitute and I think
it would be especially where you have
efficient or optimum amounts of mineral
izybelle or available nitrogen and there
too or absolutely you could cut back and
and put a little bit of iron on there
and from a visual standpoint there's
nothing liquid-liquid yeah yeah usually
it's a foliar not granular because it's
not soil uptake necessarily no no no no
that that probably and you know
depending on some of your soil chemistry
to putting on iron in the soil is you
know a business it's not we typically
have enough iron all.he and most of our
New England soils yeah we were not
deficient in iron let's put it that way
and so really you just paint in the
grass would iron sure sure and there's
nothing wrong with that it helps you cut
down on something some environment oh
well at this stage of the game here's
what helps me win
I got whisky ice and I can't mow as much
and I'd like it to be green but I don't
want it to grow why don't I go squirt
some iron yeah well you could do that
but again it's all it's all a
cost-benefit relationship on there you
know they don't give away that stuff
that's right speaking of not giving away
Carl we're passed away
getting past the witching hour any
questions III do want to get to this
question from rich he's saying that they
customized fertilization programs based
on the soil test and they applied based
on the results do you guys have any any
comments on soil testing and maybe any
values or certain methods of guidelines
that you would go by based on soil test
results well this would be other than
nitrogen well I was going to address the
nitrogen part of that because you are
guiding your fertilization based on some
soil test that you get back from either
a government lab a state lab university
life or any private labs that you are
guiding your nitrogen fertilization from
a soil test from any of those labs I can
tell you right now they're not based on
anything any data on there and there are
only two calibration data's in the
literature one came out of my lab and
one comes out of Michigan State from
Paul Ricca many many years ago they
didn't find any relationship to soil
nitrogen and turf response we did but we
had to sample every week or two weeks
throughout the year and then yeah
there's a relationship but if you're
just sending in a soil sample getting
that back for nitrogen it's not going to
work for nitrogen for phosphorous and
absolutely soil tests for phosphorous
are very very good guide your
fertilization based on their should I be
doing that the other nutrients the
relationships and calibrations are are
also fairly decent for curve maybe
except for potassium
I got a dial that went down all right
Carl see any other question before we're
out here just one more and I was
actually talking with Doug sold at a
couple weeks ago about this one Edwards
asking snow can capture atmospheric
nitrogen a lot of people refer to snow
as a slow-release fertilizer in the
spring is that a reason for earlier
green up do we have any research out
there that's been done on snow
containing any case that amounts of
nitrogen you know that's that's a good
question and I don't I don't know but I
know some of the older folks and some of
the farmers in my earlier career when I
to work with they called early spring so
snow poor man's fertilizer I suspect you
know with our with our atmosphere
deposition and there could be some
nitrogen coming down in there and maybe
it's it's getting fully absorbed I don't
know that that's an interesting question
is there's a possibility of that sure
but you know of course we can't rely on
that all the time but if we do get that
maybe dial back a little bit on there
perfect all right I think I think that's
a good place to end Frank thank you so
much Carl for joining us it's great to
see you you be safe and well huh you too
forward to see you bye everyone bye
everybody
thanks Carl
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu